welcome to this video playing against
nightmare duck okay let's take this
chance to to play the Smith [ __ ] just
for fun yeah and the slight pause is
quite quite nice maybe he does not
really know the Sicilian it sometimes
happens okay taking some time yeah okay
my knowledge of course is rather vague
of this opening but I really like this
book by Marquez summon the am in the
more our book showing a quite clearly
that the Mora can be a dangerous weapon
he has one spot Knight f6 after a five
leads to trouble but he plays with with
e six this is the very much classical
way to do it think here's one of the
cases where the standard setup is right
with Queenie to rob you one if I
remember correctly there are some some
setups where white needs them to play a
differently but here there is one of
them the case as well you can actually
play this this normal let's say setup um
interesting am i threatening me five
here already maybe that looks dangerous
um what is really well developed um yeah
there are some cases where actually what
can give a check here mmm I wonder
hmm is there some merit to that also
might be five could be could be possible
yeah maybe maybe maybe I'm spending too
much time here this is also very good in
terms of development but rook see one
coming threatening 95 maybe am this is
the the simple decision like now we'll
have to lose even more time with the
Queen yeah and right here there is an
interesting spot maybe maybe I can play
something like this night be five
business I take on e5 with the bishop de
night b5 visiting 97 maybe you can just
castle
no not sure not sure that there is
something really convincing the check on
a form maybe
now he is very close to Casa león this
is so this is a problem I wonder if i
take here play Bishop a4 b5 and then
then sacrificing them with the night
item it's pulses castling rights but
yeah is it really objectively right
probably not young check check but don't
believe if I allow him to Castle it will
be M would be a big problem and so maybe
I'm I need to I need to do something
drastic like that check yeah this is
this is not enough really I just have
one pawn and he gets got King evade I
mean a g6 does this stuff is probably
totally sufficient yeah this wasn't
really great yeah this opening result
maybe I'm it was okay at first but I
maybe should be forced probably really
this was a bit much the sacrifice but
let's let's still try to to get
something going yeah my taxi form but
maybe
yeah this further exchanges possible
piece that can attack now maybe just
calorie form for the moment maybe rook
c1 rook c7 can be an idea if he goes g6
yeah it's really just a just a piece
down really also has bishop d6 now to
just cover c 70 this is totally
sufficient
yeah this is not doing much but I I hope
for some sort of concession here like
this one time was actually a bit helpful
not a lot but it's a I maybe have
something on f7 now not objectively
speaking but just trying try to tune to
muddy the water here now this at least
gives me a pawn on d5 but yeah it's
still not not sufficient in any in any
case the night ii eight is Sam okay i
can still cannot do this and maybe i
should really take him and play play
rock c7 attacking the bishop on b7
what kid gets it gets tricky now at
least somewhat I don't know Luke f8
maybe now and there's some something now
we here threatening on e5 yeah he
probably must take it and if I was
hanging with the check I'm sure a jack
was such a great idea of black e7 is
still hanging
yeah he must take you five simply but
I'm really not sure anymore the sir has
become somewhat problematic for luck
threatening would be is six um this was
hanging if I've also hung but I needed
to take take this first check
now the two parts arbitrarily a six
Andrew k8 coming I'm not not far behind
on the clock anymore yeah this was a
very very lucky win champion like a
winner check believe totally incorrect
sacrifice check checkmate yeah I really
don't know this opening and this was
just totally wrong judgment judgment I
mean this this looks rather okay I think
I mean my development is quite quite
nice but here I'm doing something stupid
probably yeah the computer points out
there should be five here maybe this is
really better and now rook see one and
this is really dangerous right i mean
i've got all pieces in play and maybe
this is what i actually remember there
are lines like that and here here there
is a case yeah Queen a five and Bishop
behalf check now as possible this leads
to a very strong attack the computer
actually gives why the win here already
king of a Droog c7 with a winning attack
according to stock version probably this
is an area where you can blindly trust
the engine this is pure tactics yeah
this is maybe what I had in mind there
are lines like that with the PSAC and
this is this is exactly what I was
having in mind this type of attack but
this this is absolutely not sufficient
to him I mean probably I can just play
on with some
normal move but this this is a chat
absolutely not enough chan kim yeah just
bad player tib like it's really just a
piece up for pong you know I mean they
can they can take on g5 now for example
just trading stuff but okay it was it
was still everything was ok for for
black hair you can take twice now on g5
this is this is the the easiest actually
because it looks at this I cannot take
the b7 bishop they are here also
blackest of course completely winning
check here it started to get slightly
slightly tricky but he can still take g5
and now Queen g4 yeah this I thought
that then I would have taken shower I
guess then maybe yeah I hope for the
best but it's not it's not enough it's
not enough i can just go here yeah i
really don't don't have any great and
great trick here yeah auntie em I'm just
taking this and I material up early if
three was probably simpler but ok i only
had 29 seconds around here yeah this was
a lucky win but i'm still instructive
that that this here is so strong with
Bishop b5 and the sacrifice is coming is
very dangerous yeah White has of course
it's a full development right
everything's developed and black still
on is far behind okay thanks for
watching